[音楽]
うんうんうーん
うわぁばーわー
ua
ん
[音楽]
あ夜になっている
理科室もありますあ一のはいありがとうございます
御社の吉祥理念にもございますグローバルな会社だというきれい年
ローバルもはいグローバルでございますはいはいえーと
配布レディースどちらのですはいはいどうぞ ir ぞゴミだったらや
どうぞあっ
[音楽]
よろしくお願い致します
じゃないん
あインターネット接続が不安定
おっしゃるようください
音音が
あっ止まったう
ん
ban
dha
ていた
あお世話になります先日内定の通知をいただきました絵だと申しますが
すいません左右担当の山田様はいらっしゃいますでしょうか
はいはいよろしくお願い致します
ああああああ
はいありがとうございます
今ご不在
お願いします
いらっしゃいます
いやー
ひぁっにペーターさんの大規模
どちらですか
ん
月穂はいん
ありもちろんサーガ第一行でございます
ん
小さなサークルたんですけどね昨日を明日共有しておりましてサーブじゃねバスケ
アップ
実はの私もだけど相談ですね急遽ムシですよね大津られず本当に良い所ぜ
ご自身を
牛の部位に例えたら所です後ろ沿い
[音楽]
d っっ
戸田一さん入ってくるぞ
していません
うん
時間は30分
それまでに何かしらの結論をまとめていただいて代表者の方に最高説明をしていただく
そういった流れになります
それではスタートしてください
宜しくお願いしますございます
[音楽]
悉皆進行方を決めた方がいいと思うんですけれども
も知るを受ければ僕はいはいおれある惚れ
おれオレで学級委員違ってたのだ生んだよじゃあ太く色しか俺デー
4よっしゃー
じゃあ段階系あるしたーー
うんはい
俺はね朝早く来るのが入っても早朝3時
どうそしたら装置さんちきたらも切る前くらい変えれる予定だ
こちらも残響ないじゃこれいいじゃない
java ほかほかの意見なんかあるとはい
これは言えめちゃくちゃ良い人数増やそ
倍デー
by にしたら働く鹿ハブになる
by の仕事効率なるからねえ
井下の
よしたろ
みんなどうした元気出していこう
だろうねぇ
ちな
ん
me
私からは以上です
このあとあの会社説明の方うちの子村からさせて頂きますのでそのままお待ちください
吉野が
やります
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
初めまして人時の園田です
明日を情熱と技術で切り開く
弊社はこの信念のもと次世代のマーケットを創出してきた
リーディングカンパニーです
国内だけではなく海岸至るまで
グローバルに事業を展開しテクノロジーの力で新たな価値を創造
豊かな社会の実現に貢献することをミッションとしております
能力獲得の教育制度や違いを認め合える community
仕事だけではなくプライベートも充実できるような勤務体系などこれら
労働環境を充実していくことが社員の成長そして引いては弊社の成長につながると考え
ております
もう10年前とは比較にならないくれ
世の中全体が格段に便利になりました
私たちはこれで満足していません
便利な世の中をもっともっと推し進めたい
インターネットができることって
まだまだ思う
個人のビールだけでない
ビジネスのフィールドの多いでも
人やモノの流れをもっと効率的に
もっとアーっていうもっと便利にし
そうすれば皆さんの生活がより豊かになるはずです
たちは
インターネットとテクノロジーを掛け合わせることで
そんなより良い社会を実現していくことを目指しています
この業界はまだまだ生まれたばかりですが
10年号
20年後にはん
爆発的に拡大していると申します
我々
うん
範囲だけで今回同に出演していただきましたすいまだ真理子さんとサンシャイン池崎
金谷 year
ああそうだどうでした今回楽しかったです本当に何かも一瞬だったんでもっと最初バー
でたかったんです
もう美人な人って一緒でいいです石工一瞬で人を寄せ付けますから
やったありがとうございます初たイベント初対面のロスよ
おっおっましたえっ
僕も見てましたんですよもうガチガチに見えましたよはあああもう
てるんだけどウィッグ39
0サティじゃあ
[音楽]
ブーブー言ったんですよ
骨をされていない母いないです見なきゃいけないんですよ
んでしちゃダメだよクズつまりデイズ入りえっ
ステージは全基蟻ございました野党ご紹介いたしました
あ車ありがとう
中世
はいというわけで今回ですね色んな方と一緒に就活であるあるをやってみたんですけど
もいかがだったでしょうか
ちなみに就活生は自分に合った愛車を見つけることが一番大事だと思うんですけれども
なかなか時間やお金の関係上ですね全国を回ってその企業さんの説明を聞きに行くの
とても大変だと思います
そんな
木いつでもどこでも気軽に会社説明会聞けたらいいと思いませんが
さらに今後の就職活動ってオンラインが知立になんですよ多分
いや多分じゃなくて絶対そんな時にライブ会社説明会のディックライブでそれが無料で
できちゃうんです
メールアドレスのみですぐ登録可能で無料で
恋愛部会社説明会にさんが可能です日本中の色々な企業が見れるので就活の参考になり
ます
興味のある企業さんに対してダイレクトメッセージを送ることができまして距離が近い
コミュニケーションをとることが可能です
就活生のみなさんぜひチェックしてみてください動画の会社だから今すぐ登録してみて
くださいじゃあな
[音楽]
elp 2